yeah I think that they thought well he's
a fat guy clearly we need to get him a
CPAP lady you know you you you could do
something I'm just trying to figure out
how to would you know tactfully so glad
to be back here on a ladder with Crowder
lovely guest friend of mine friend of
the program that when he was on no one
was listening it's when the show first
started Rob wolf calm one of the the
guys who spearheaded the Paleo diet
movement I guess I don't need to say his
name because his website is his name but
Rob well thanks for being on the show I
always glad to bring down property
values thanks yeah exactly you're
literally in a double window screen with
with fun dip dance oh I don't think you
need to have be concerned with that okay
before we go into I think it'll be
interesting to have you talk with with
fund it because he's in a diet now and
he's making some progress so I'm sure
you can help them Rob have you you must
have just gone bananas when the FDA
changed officially their food pyramid
chart well I mean it's gone through
multiple iterations every five years
they have kind of a review and there's a
public review period where people can
submit commentary and thoughts about the
whole process but it's really just kind
of rearranging deck chairs on the
Titanic like nothing comes of the
scientific input other than the folks on
the back end of that story so yeah I
mean it's it's frustrating but I think
we're seeing a lot of changes happening
from a market kind of driven perspective
versus a top-down approach so right I
think we'll have this war won and then
they will change the recommendations to
reflect something reasonable so do you
are you saying that they are incorrect
and telling me that six servings of
fruit loops is healthier than a sirloin
steak and salad well I mean incorrect
based off of them whose I think the
system that's going on right now then
it's a great process but if you really
want to help people and avert the
obesity type 2 diabetes epidemic that we
have in our country and in Western
societies then it's probably not a great
recommendation how dare you how dare you
be anti science okay well so it's
something we've been talking about for a
while obviously and fun dip I don't want
to reveal anything you know obviously
this is your story but fun dip right now
is is in the process of losing weight so
fun that why don't you tell Rob what it
is that you're doing and what they have
you doing right now
your dietitians or whoever you're
working with well the the doctor today
said I don't have any diabetes which is
good my thyroid now that I'm on meds for
that I am back on track but I refuse to
take the medicine for my prolactin oma
that makes me angry and cranky so they
keep saying go get em yeah in green
whiskey's a bad combo yeah but the basic
deal is I need to still set up an MRI
but I have lost I was at like 411 and
I'm down to three 89.5 I was just
weighed probably about an hour and a
half ago and the doctor so already
you've lost a Justin Bieber well the
more you lose the better yeah exactly so
but fun dip you brought in and this is
where I think Rob is really you know in
Rob and I disagree on some things we
agree on some things but the diet they
have you doing you actually uploaded a
video so they had you eaten like lots of
carrots right fruit fruit cups fun dip
well they didn't specify necessarily the
fruit cups but I'm adding those to kind
of replace the cheese puffs some wean
myself slowly to where I'm eating
nothing but twigs berries and and raw
meat just as an aside when I was doing
molecular biology research we used just
throw that in there as a standard for
quantifying UV release and in gel
electrophoresis so they have a
multiplicity of uses some of these food
products very good I don't think that's
how fund it was putting them to use it
was more so that down the gullet use
well I I have to tell you though for
folks that do still eat them eat them
with chopsticks because then you don't
get the orange fingers yeah that's a
good idea then you won't floor
in the dark so only your : will but yeah
so Rob so fun dip right as a blank
canvas he's looking he's getting how
very large to miss Oh God
see this is one of those things works
like we've talked about this some people
have a hood pass some people have a fat
pass obviously I can't make the jokes
and then fun dip Energex and I don't
know if what's correct to laugh at
contribute to it but unless you gain if
you gain another 50 or 60 pounds you're
more than welcome to join the club it's
like that dentist on Seinfeld you anti
den tight bastard so Rob what would you
have firstly by the way fun dip again
I'm not saying this to be insulting you
know but the fact that you don't have
you know cholesterol issues or diabetes
I mean you're like up
you said you over 400 pounds right fun
dip well not anymore I'm 389 point five
but you're a marvel of science and I and
no high blood pressure either my cat has
higher blood pressure than me and Rob
we've talked about this fun dip drinks
like a pot of coffee a day and there are
a lot of intensive anti-diabetic effects
with coffee so firstly can someone
answer me that question why hasn't fun
to have diabetes you know it's
interesting not everybody who becomes
overweight becomes diabetic not
everybody that's type 2 diabetic is
overweight and that's some of the the
difficulty in pinning this stuff down
there's a lot of unique genetic
variation in there and you know there's
some interesting studies where there's
certain cohorts of people that are
significantly overweight but they never
experience any of these metabolic -
ranging diseases type 2 diabetes
cardiovascular disease neurodegenerative
disease and so it becomes kind of
complex ferreting out you know who has
the real problems and what do we need to
do to address that from an orthopedic
standpoint we could make an argument
that being lighter would be good it'll
be better on your hips better on your
knees
and how old are you better on his wife
45 years old they've supplementing with
vitamin D which is giving me more energy
as well yeah my back went out I ended up
call and Steven because I knew that his
back had gone out because it back
back out expert yeah yeah my back's been
out in the purpose since like 2010 back
and he's out oh geez
well that's the Planet Fitness video
thing is I want to dive into it but we
have to go to a break in 30 seconds but
yeah you know you're it's it's funny
that you say that Rob it's hard like you
can pull you've we've talked about this
before you can pull people out of the
population and different weights and all
them will have different problems it
seems like the crossover is very
difficult to find okay let's just go to
a break real quick that way we can let
Rob dig in with us clubs and actually
teach us louder with Crowder we'll be
back after the break back on ladder with
Crowder Rob wolf Rob wolf calm one of
the most popular health and fitness
podcasts in the history of the universe
right Rob yeah but that's a clear sign
that there's a lack of real talent in
that vertical yeah yeah it's kind of
like us with news and politics but so
fund it was talking about this so he's
looking at to lose weight so give me an
idea
fun dip you know would come in and he
would have Hebrew national hot dogs for
breakfast I mean we have it on video
it's beef yeah I don't think there's
anything wrong I see no real issue with
that yeah yeah yes so now they have you
doing what some people would see is more
traditional right Rob like more
traditional dieting calorie restriction
but not necessarily looking at the food
groups what would you do with fund ev to
make him the best fund if he can be well
you know the the key with this stuff and
it gets a little geeky but we need to
find foods that you just really can't
overeat with and so we were talking
about you know the majestic cheeto here
a minute or just I mean we need to call
them orange cheese puffs so that we
don't have undue branding you know lean
meats fruits vegetables even things like
a baked potato plain versus a baked
potato with a bunch of ranch and sour
cream and butter on it we if we move
towards simple meals
simple plates then it becomes very
difficult to overeat on that but one of
the the things that we find is that
people say that they become bored and
kind of woven into our genetics is this
thing called palate fatigue like we just
get bored with the stuff that's in front
of us and we now live in
environment where we have an infinite
variety of foods an infinite variety of
flavors and textures and whatnot and if
you look at the strategies that
professional food eaters employ like a
guy will be on a contest to eat ten
pounds of ice cream in like 15 minutes
or something and the guy is eight pounds
in and he bogs down and the guy will
order a plate of salty french fries eat
some french fries to get a change in the
flavor and then he's able to eat the
rest of the food which is really kind of
counterintuitive you know you figure
that once your belly is full that you're
completely full but a lot of our
appetite is driven by our brain and the
flavors that we send to the brain and
whatnot will determine how much we eat
or if we eat within kind of reasonable
parameters so what tends to be
successful and this is regardless of if
you eat low carb or paleo or vegan or
whatever it tends to only may that word
we don't allow I know I know show no you
know a minutes yeah I don't have the
warm snuggly is for them either but you
know there's a reality that you can pick
almost any eating plan and it performs
better than the American Dietetics
recommended plan which is take any food
that's available and food is very
strongly in quotation points like a
Twinkie is considered a food and you're
just supposed to limit the portion sizes
on that but when you have these foods
that have been cooked up by a chemist to
be hyper palatable and taste really good
and have this amazing you know kind of
mouthfeel it's very very difficult
what's the Lay's commercial bet you
can't eat just one
oh yeah you know they had in Canada they
had that high sticker Mark Messier
pushing those things like I mean it was
just like just pushing them on kids and
you know what I thought I bet you he's
right and I bought myself some Lay's
yeah and you didn't eat just one so you
know one bag yeah just one bag one
pallet so it's interesting that almost
any dietary approach that limits food
options to some degree will tend to be
more successful than what the government
is telling us to do but yet then the
government dietitians tell us that we
have orthorexia or eating disorders
right by limiting certain types of food
so it's this it's an interesting
rope-a-dope where so why does the
governor
let me ask you this but not to get
political but it is political show why
does the government seem to consistently
want to get more and more involved I
mean even listen I I don't believe that
the government is necessarily inherently
bad or inherently altruistic right
they're bad okay
fund it but they're they're increasingly
getting involved in an area where
they've been wrong it would seem that if
they want to help people they would hire
someone like you or more biochemists
right and to do medical research and
nutritional research as opposed to just
eat 12 servings of grains a day well I
don't mix I'm gonna make some folks
angry because they're you know I there
are a number of people who tend to be
more conservative leaning that live in
states where farm subsidies are kind of
part and parcel with their existence and
we really didn't see this issue emerge
until around 1970 1971 when we
aggressively subsidized the production
of food in the United States and we had
a couple of years where food was just
rotting in warehouses and so people said
well we can't just increase food
production and let it rot so they
started encouraging food / - food
manufacturers to figure out ways of
making this food long shelf-life and
stable and that really was the beginning
of you know snack wells and all the junk
food that we see today so we have really
now well are those still around I think
they're still around and they still have
an American Heart Association stand well
is that the green box right there we
have like all the cookies oh they're
devil's food cookies word just insanely
good they're not bad I wouldn't kick him
out of bed for sure so so you know I
mean it's it's a really complex story
you have a lot of money a lot of
political interests that are vested in
this you have a lot of people that
derive their current income from what I
call farmer welfare and which pisses a
lot of people off oh I know what we
talked about talk about that with lyric
Keith - and yeah it's funny this idea
and she I think she's wrong in a lot of
issues obviously but this idea that well
we have to save the farmer and anytime
you get into that by the way the welfare
is being given to these giant corporate
mega farms - the government's involved
just like banks you create a little no
it's not the little guys and it's like
oh we have to say
the orange farm in Florida because of
tomatoes in Colorado that's probably
scientifically inaccurate they probably
won't grow tomatoes in Colorado but you
get my point Robert yes I do I do
yeah and so I mean it's a it's a complex
issue and you know interestingly I don't
know if you guys talked about this on
the show but after 60 years of
demonizing dietary cholesterol the
government did a complete reduction on
that story and part of that story said
they'll paraphrase it and I'll totally
butcher it but the in the future we need
to be much less arrogant about the
assumptions that we make and let the
data really stand for itself and and
that was kind of a bold statement to
come out of a you know an institution
like like the folks that put that that
report out that's what I was bringing up
initially and I misspoke I was talking
about the food pyramid I meant the
cholesterol the guy cholesterol dietary
guidelines I mean you must have just
been through the roof happy about that
because people have been saying that for
years and it's like doctors have been
slow to get on board because they're
still afraid of cholesterol until
finally they said hey this is just the
reality yeah you know there was never
any data to support the idea that
cholesterol cause heart disease in the
beginning that dietary cholesterol cause
heart disease in the beginning and we
span you 50 60 years and billions of
dollars trying to prove something that
never had really a scrap of evidence
right from the get-go and and there's
why were they trying to prove it though
that's my question why did they set out
to seems that they set out to prove
cholesterol as the villain not is it
good is it bad it seems like if you look
at the studies they were geared toward
proving cholesterol as a dietary culprit
am I wrong or why don't know they did in
the folks that wrote the report were
largely non scientists who were
vegetarian uh and so that's where it
really all started from you know there
was a committee that sat down to write
these reports and they were vegetarian
and and there is some reality in
research the research world that if you
feed rabbits cholesterol that they will
develop atherosclerosis but rabbits are
herbivores are not omnivores like we are
and so we react to dietary cholesterol
very very differently and there is a
genetic disease familial
hypercholesterolemia where folks tend to
die young they die from coronary artery
disease they have except
high blood cholesterol and lipoprotein
levels and so they had a genetic disease
where they saw it very rapidly advancing
cardiovascular disease and they had an
animal model that seemed to say that
dietary cholesterol was a causative
factor there's some correlation there
but then when you even in the early
iterations of this story that was very
weak science in the science that was
really trying to implicate dietary
cholesterol as being causative and
cardiovascular disease there was really
nothing there but there were some some
kind of red herrings out there that
directed people in a false direction and
created a story that was palatable yeah
well that's what my dad's doctor
actually was a great doctor but even he
was like well you know keep your eggs
limited and so my dad did you know the
green smoothies for and I talked about
that I did that for a long time just
horrible for my thyroid
you know blending up writing fruit is
fine with some you know some like kefir
and somehow actually put in some egg
yolks I basically made like a homemade
eggnog it's delicious right but yeah the
the green smoothie trend now I mean you
see that health expert on TV with your
drink I can't I can't use the actual I
guess patented term it said let's call
it nutritious smoothie right and
everyone's just like well if I just
throw everything gonna go ape crap crazy
in a blender I'll be healthy like a
goose but oh well yeah I tend to eat a
lot of salmon and a lot of flank steak
and even ground beef if I make a decent
sloppy joe and and don't use the bun I
can't imagine there's anything wrong
with tomato sauce and ground beef now I
mean it's great stuff and you know the
the thing that should drive all this
particularly on an individual level
you should be able to experiment and
figure out what works for you clearly
I've kind of a you know this Paleo
ancestral diet kind of orientation let's
say I'm crazy and I don't know what I'm
talking about though but people could
try this stuff on like a sweater you you
get some blood work done you do
something for 30 or 60 days get some
blood work done at the end of it and if
your cholesterol looks better and you
look feel and perform better then we're
on a good track if things are looking
goofy then we have some really simple
other templates that we can use again
whether it's vegetarian or vegan or
what-have-you let's really let the
outcome base medicine drive that store
well you know what it's funny you say
that because full disclosure Rob and I
have worked together behind the scenes a
little bit really just kind of some
advice so when I was I have the
cholesterol numbers in front of me may I
rob yes so this was my cholesterol was
219 actually was always pretty good my
cholesterol was 219 LDL 140 HDL 60
triglycerides were a little little
higher than ideal at 94 and I wasn't I
was doing a lot of green smoothies kind
of more not vegetarian but limiting the
meat because that's what I was told then
I said okay started eating more eggs
meat in the morning not no carb not
paleo full disclosure but more focused
more on on meat and didn't bother with
fat and eliminating a lot of refined
carbohydrates cholesterol went from 219
to 178 LDL went from 140 to 115 HDL
stayed about the same it went to 54
triglycerides dropped from 94 to 59 yeah
and the triglycerides are the indicator
of how insulin-resistant you are right
so you went from heading down the road
towards diabetes to completely pulling
that that back and you're never going to
become diabetic from that right and
every well controlled randomized control
trial that's compared like a little bit
higher fat higher protein diet with a
higher carbohydrate diet particularly
refined carbohydrates we see this again
and again when people eat more protein
more fat their blood lipids tend to go
in a favorable direction they tend to
spontaneously eat less which it's funny
the researchers will then add more food
to try to keep the calories even because
in science you do want to compare apples
to apples right but the irony is that if
you just simply eat more protein in fat
you tend to eat fewer calories overall
and that's the problem ultimately is
people overeat and that was kind of my
point earlier about the neuro regulation
of appetite if we eat certain foods they
tend to tell our brain hey we're good
we're finished we've eaten enough and
then you're satisfied you don't feel
hungry and it has all these great
metabolic benefits too so probably the
best thing would be to eat the nuts eat
the eat the hot dogs without the bun eat
more steaks eat more chicken and then
gotta have some greens out imagine my
two favorite greens are broccoli and
Brussels sprouts yeah
yeah lots of fruits and vegetables
within that that template and I think
your said so like breakfast could be the
Hebrew nation hot dog with a hold on one
second I have to let you go we'll be
right back after the break with a
personalized fun dip diet plan Rob Wolfe
stay tuned we're back
Rob Wolfe on ladder with Crowder okay so
Rob we asked you a question then you got
all sciency on us perfect cure for
insomnia I talk and people fall asleep
well you know that's a big part of your
of your plan with recoveries proper
sleep you're a big guy better you will
be healthier across it right so they
they did recommend today that I need to
take a sleep apnea test and I'm really
leery of that because of all the things
glued to your head I don't know how I
would even survive it you know I would
hold man so the deal with sleep apnea is
that if you aren't sleeping well that
can make you very very insulin resistant
we work a lot with police military and
fire and those folks because of their
shift work even if the well even if they
exercise a lot they become very insulin
resistant and can look like a type-2
diabetic so if you have sleep
disturbance there could be an argument
for using like a CPAP machine to help
you sleep better and you use it for two
or three months until your weight drops
and your but they said that you weren't
insulin resistant though yeah I think
that they thought well he's a fat guy
clearly we need to get him a CPAP ready
you know you you you can do something
I'm just trying to figure out how to
would you know tactfully shifting gears
some way you could get a jawbone or some
sort of a sleep monitoring app on your
iPhone or smartphone and if they have
that for the a rotary dial for that I
got that in the basement okay perfect
but you know there's some really cheap
and expected inexpensive things that can
give you an idea if you're just having
terrible sleep
if you're having terrible sleep it
market it by you're waking up multiple
times a night and whatnot then you could
go in get a sleep study possibly use a
CPAP to get you over the hump so that if
you sleep better you will absolutely
become less insulin resistant and you
will lose weight more effectively even
though you don't seem to have that
problem like you seem decide you don't
snore a lot well you don't have an
insulin resistance that's for sure had
no insulin resistance I don't know if I
snore a lot the cat doesn't say so
hard it's hard to say but I do I do get
up now that I'm over 40 and wake up a
couple of times at night to take care of
stuff as far as you know restroom and
that well you know in that that's an
interest that is another interesting
side effect of carrying extra fat mass
is that we tend area with within our fat
yeah I'm gonna be be burned at the stake
within our fat we have an enzyme called
aromatase which converts testosterone
into estrogen and when that estrogen
level goes up then it tends to irritate
the prostate so that is juice when I go
on bulking cycles I always notice I mean
I don't go on bulking cycles but when
I'm like hey it's winter and I'm lifting
heavy so I'm not concerned about it and
I put on maybe 10 pounds I always notice
I have to go yeah bathroom yeah so I
mean that that is one of the sneaky side
effects of carrying excess body fat is
that you will convert testosterone into
estrogen and and biology played a really
interesting trick on men the the part of
the brain that regulates testosterone
levels responds to estrogen so your
estrogen levels go up and then the brain
gets this feedback loop and it sees high
estrogen levels and then it says well we
have adequate testosterone so it
actually down regulates testosterone
production and you're getting this very
vicious feed-forward kind of kind of
situation with yeah that's exactly what
the prolactin omma it does it okay it's
on the pituitary gland and it's this
growth and it reduces the testosterone
at any and it increases the estrogen and
I end up liking art French films with
cans oh we could talk later he also
admitted on fund if also admitted on air
that he would engage in relations with a
man so he is definitely going full we
have address Rob another oh sorry Rob
I'm sorry has many tutus does that count
you know something I would throw to your
doctor and in some Doc's freak out about
this but while you're trying to lose
weight while you're in that process
seeing if the doctor would be willing to
get you on a remedy X which is an
aromatase inhibitor you you could make a
very strong argument for that improving
your prostate function and also helping
to naturally raise your testosterone
levels although with the prolactin oma
there may be some contraindications with
that but that might be something to run
up the flagpole with that the prostate
thing is called a Rimma wat a remedy
remedy X and it originally was a cancer
drug for breast cancer that responds to
estrogen but what it does is it prevents
the conversion of testosterone into
estrogen and then there's also like
clomiphene citrate clomid I know but it
acts differently right where it's uh is
it like an estrogen with an analogue
kind of clomid actually stimulates the
production of testosterone it produces
luteinizing hormone and actually causes
the the release of testosterone and so
that would be if somebody due to
metabolic issues or inflammation like
they've basically taken their testicles
off line and you need condoms life is
done man okay so Rob Rob okay we don't
have too much time and I feel like we've
we've already ruined reputation so let
me bring it back like simplify for fun
dip right because we might even sort of
fitness log here on the YouTube channel
for those listening to rest really
louder with credit com you can stay up
to date
what should fund it be doing right like
you see I'm bringing in his lunch box
what would be you know fund it loves his
Hebrew nationals he loves his beef he
loves you know and Sam and all that
stuff what should he be doing to make it
sustainable and just lose weight and not
be like you said not be longing for
stuff the Cheetos you know the point
there about sustainability is really the
key and you usually what we need is
enough variety so that we stick on a
reasonable plan not so much variety that
the variety becomes
but a cheese puffs so you know like the
Hebrew national in the morning with a
you know a couple of handfuls of nuts
way to you you know do a couple ounces
in a ziploc bag lunch salmon with a
bunch of veggies the you know
epidemiologically the coffee that seems
to be the more you drink the longer you
live so I know that many yeah yeah about
beans and cheese I like I like beans to
a certain extent I like sauerkraut and I
need cheese I have to have like a good
10-year cheddar is that okay that's fine
that's fine yeah you know so within that
that framework just get as much variety
as you can but keep the meals relatively
simple like one or two items per meal
and then maybe you run a week or two
with basically the same breakfast lunch
dinner and then you really change it up
so instead of the Hebrew national for
breakfast then it's like a hot link and
some coconut chips or something like
it's still kind of the same template but
you're changing it up you're changing
the the textures you're changing the
seasonings and then that way you won't
be completely burned out on this versus
through national and then going crazy
well yeah just ditch the damn fruit cups
fun dip that's what I'm saying like I
don't the problem is you have like these
nutritionists who go out there and you
know they're given fun dip advice based
on like you said the FDA guidelines you
know which are outdated already and
they're even acknowledging now so fun
dip I think you'll be happier with this
you'll be able to eat the stuff you like
and I mean I think it'll just I think
it'll work that's why I wanted to have
an intervention with Rob and bring him
on he's he he was throwing you under the
bus to die you and your doctor who
that's just my destination my
fascination with London but yet he's got
the TARDIS he know what's going on but
the red double-decker bus ties in with
London Calling my show on Saturday
nights 10 p.m. to midnight I play the
bed right let's do that let's let Rob
get his plug in Rob if people want to
find you and learn more about you know
sensible diet health nutrition like you
where should they go well now that I'm
on parole they can usually find me at
Rob wolf com2 bees are Oh bee bee
wol f and then i have a podcast that
oddly enough is in the top five on
itunes the Paleo solution so you can
check that says true and we've stolen
some of your guests Gary Wilson with the
your brain oh yeah your brain on porn
was a great guest who yeah if people
don't listen just do it after a while
what you're bout gosh he's like what I
took me a while to catch it and then I
realized of course it comes from a a
perverted place with fun dip so Rob
thank you so much for coming on and what
we would love to do is have you come
back on and and we'll follow fun dips
progress and see where he's going and if
it doesn't work we'll totally throw you
under the bus and let me know perfect
perfect any any failure on your part it
you can attribute to me there you go
it's all Rob's fault yes any success we
will attribute to Oprah Rob well thank
you very much but we must let you know
Doge
bye guys this video subscribe by
clicking my face or click this video
next to me it's playing right now in a
box how do we do that that's the magic
of the internet is it still playing
still playing I don't want to look at it
still playing isn't it